hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades in a world filled with triple-a
titles and sequels it can sometimes be a
little difficult to notice the potential
of smaller indie titles one in
particular looks to be doing something
different something unique and dare I
say it's pioneering I'm talking about a
way ours not only does it have the most
charismatic and then Deering directors
behind it Joseph Aras we'll get to him
soon but it also has a new take on
cinematic
cooperative storytelling here are 8
things you should know about a way out
let's quickly set the scene the campaign
revolves around Vincent and Leo who meet
one another in prison set back in the
1970s the two share a connection and a
tale of revenge unfolds you don't know
anything about me man
maybe not but Harvey kills someone very
close to me
with or without you I'm going after each
character has their own personality with
Leo likely to become more aggressive
impulsive and a little hot-headed to say
the least
Vincent on the other hand is calculated
he's in control at all times and this
dichotomy fuels each new experience
running through a way out if you haven't
heard of a way out and you're trying to
place the genre or similar games in that
vein you'll have trouble as this is a
new approach to video game storytelling
the closest games I can think of are
heavy rain and beyond two souls but
imagine that in a two-player format with
a much higher level of player movement
and interactivity and that to play
element is vital as the entire game must
be played with two people present that
could be at home on your easy clean
leather couch or via the power of the
Internet and those digital friends we
have online a way out to use a split
screen the majority of the time allowing
us to experience both sides of the story
simultaneously it's even possible for
one player to be in a cutscene as the
other one walks past so of course I'm
going to be clowning around in the
background of my friends shots if you've
ever played a heist on GTA and wondered
what the heck the other players are
doing then a way out will better suit
your needs as each player can see the
other at all times
working together becomes easier and the
entire story can be seen from two
different viewpoints if you are as
ancient as I am I'm sure you'll remember
split-screen gaming as a child and my
word it's great to see it back in 2018
the level of detail and dare I say it
replayability looks to be staggering an
example of this can be seen in the early
demo which asks players to decide who
will take the gun on a mission to rob a
gas station it may seem like an
inconsequential choice but it definitely
has repercussions and like I said
earlier will you give the firearm to the
hothead or the calm one nobody moves
stay calm
this is only the starting point to as
NPCs react differently to each character
if all works well the desire to replay
the campaign will be high as you may be
left thinking what would have happened
if Vincent took the gun instead hey i'm
joseph aris writer director of a way out
joseph Aras is the mastermind behind a
way out with his filmmaking background
crossing over to video games in the past
with brothers a tale of two sons far as
himself is the most passionate
enthusiastic and honest people I have
ever seen in the games industry and he
isn't afraid to speak his mind even when
talking about the games publisher EA and
this is my idea doesn't have anything
with the link between a way out and
Electronic Arts may be causing many
people to look past this one due to the
underhanded loot box issues in many of
their titles but once again joseph has
some words of reassurance for you all
publishers got sometimes you know that's
how it is as a way out is a two-player
title you'd be forgiven if you're
expecting to buy two copies to play the
game with others here is the brilliance
of this project as shiplake technology
will work across ps4 PC and Xbox but of
course this isn't cross-platform to make
sure that one's out there here's what
happens once you invite a friend to the
game they will have a demo version of
the title download it to their console
or PC they can only access it when
you're with them though in fact I'll
turn this over to the director as he can
explain this in a more eloquent way than
I you don't have to buy two copies this
one you only buy one copy and you invite
your friend to play with you for free I
mean the entire game for free for real
well said sir and finally when can we
expect a way out Joseph's games coming
out March 23rd 2018
thank you very much I freaking love that
guy I'll most definitely be picking up
this game but what do you think does the
EI effect scare you or is this on your
list of games to play in 2018 I'd love
to know your thoughts in the comments
below I'm Adam from Playstation grenades
it's been a damn pleasure I'll see you
next time